welcome to this video yeah this is round
five coverage recap of this fifth round
of the Tata Steel tournament a little
bit late this upload time but I couldn't
really do it her idea the thing was that
for this round I actually did the live
broadcast for the ISIS eat together with
Grand Master Jo Benjamin yeah Joel was
the main analyst in this sem in this do
i was moderating her show in a way and
also helping to analyze a little bit it
was a really long broadcast almost six
hours and i can assure you if you won on
the air for six hours after that you
don't do much besides worth eating a bit
in falling asleep so I decided to not
really produce the video after this
marathon but rather delay this until the
next day so that i'm actually awake when
the video is produced ok let's have a
look at this round it was a very
interesting round i think many
interesting games and this means that i
have to be a bit brief about some of the
games that were they had that some of
them even have points of interest but if
i look at them all this is a two hour
video so we start with Rasheeda graph
with white against Luke fan valley both
players didn't really have a good
tournament so far let's see how they
fare in this encounter yeah when when
you place e 6 a-6 the con variation not
a very usual choice for heavy normally
is an idol player and does not go for
that so often main difference between
this kind of setup anthem the night off
for example is that why it has this
option of playing c4 which cards did in
the World Championship match for example
but why Sheila graph here only when for
Bishop e2 only is the wrong word
yeah he provided this option to play c4
and now we get a standard type of
position that could have her could have
also risen from night off it's in fact
transposing to a ravening and kind of
setup I'm not totally great on this
pronunciation but it's not so far off at
least when I compared this to Jo
Benjamin's pronunciation mind was bitten
a bit nearer the trivia to the truth
okay well this kind of line was very
popular even back in the 80s and 90s
when Kasparov was still playing he was a
real champion of the set up with black
had many encounters against him Anatoly
Karpov in the 80s later against Nigel
short against Ireland lots of great
players on the on the white side as well
on it's a flexible setup for white with
good peace development White has some
more than one idea and he can sometimes
play for a g4 g5 base the tech I can
play in the center and why Sheila graphy
is going for a central approach he's
putting a 4 out Bishop f3 so those
bishops are more aimed towards the Queen
side and this is not so much leading to
a king side attack the idea is also if
we look at this here that white is now
threatening to play a 5 and getting a
piece to be six so black fields inclined
to play b6 and this is the start of a
tactical phase of the game initiated by
the move a5 somewhat funny thing is that
both sides he has spent huge chunks of
time despite this being a very
well-known of theoretical position when
Valley is actually an expert on this
opening so it's kind of surprising that
he spent more than 30 minutes up to this
point and Russia was normally really
excellently
prepared also spend lots of time so it
was kind of surprising and yeah white
blasts open the position with 85 and d5
and already skirmish share based on the
long diagonal like plate now rook to
eight that's a necessary move really if
you do this then something like this
leads to trouble yeah back here here and
why them ends up being a much better
this is the right move and there are
some examples in the database of that
but I could really figure out what the
current three article stated I mean it
looked like the statistics suggest this
is about equal but it's hard to tell
without them super deep analysis yeah
Queenie to was played 95 it's quite
logical and now we trade down to a
simplified position it's clear that if
we look at the next couple of moves that
this wasn't the greatest opening result
ever for white yam a simple count of
pawns and yeah it gets us to the to the
conclusion that we have equal material
and well black has this active position
and this week pawn on e5 to attack after
some trade cm yeah we came to this and
from here it is a pretty straightforward
affair leading to a position where black
is just this pawn up but it's all on one
side of the ball it's very pure position
if you want there's the pawns have not
moved but just just one extra point like
this is not a position that black should
win and the the way the game went
basically confirmed that this should be
a draw the only fun little funny side
note
funny is a bit it's a bit much maybe but
there's still situation where I'm
situations where I'm amazed at what
computers are evaluate I could just just
want to show you one thing yeah in this
situation I think it's really amusing
that if you use this if you use a
computer and you give it to this
position it there are still evaluations
of a pretty substantial advantage for
black by the engines while this position
is I mean the dread dead is to draw ever
yeah I mean there is no one dead is dead
there is no one exaggerated to form of
that with this is just completely drawn
this is even a draw without the h
porneia when black has two pawns because
of the here the the wrong khalid bishop
yeah if you look at it with table basis
of course the computer place perfectly
but just wrap your calculation and basic
evaluation the computer all engines the
thing that black is substantially better
it's really funny yeah they really have
no grasp or phone of a fortress type of
situation in the game white got the age
point back and they agree to draw it was
them there was no real winning chance if
it is on one side of the board three
against two five against four this kind
of thing can be can be winning with the
minor piece that's not too three against
two okay so a draw in this game and then
we had to ding Liren our tournament it's
not the tournament leader Yvonne chagas
leave the tournament but the ding was on
second place with three wins in a row
yeah he lost the first round and then
three wins in the following games yeah
we had a Slav against even shook even
shook is leading the tournament he only
conceded one draw he won all three white
games with the open Sicilians yeah
interestingly enough we got a triangle
Slav wear white has some choice now um
ding shows the most conserved
movie 3 on not a bad move obviously my
movie is Quincy too I always liked the
idea to later get to a situation where i
get the bishop out and play III so very
harmonious set up the drawback is of
course that it moves the Queen quite
early and sometimes often in the opening
yet if like this that for example you
can take I have to move the Queen I have
to move it again yeah but I get a
pneumonia said that this is actually
line that i can recommend very much for
white yeah but III is of course fine as
well but just it's a bit conservative b3
b6 now they develop it's all very normal
and in this position however it's quite
surprising the next move ya dig now
place g3 which is a novelty not very
surprising that this is novelty because
it looks a it looks really creative I
mean white has played III so the most
natural move when the world is to play
Bishop d3 I mean maybe Bishop e2 we are
but Bishop d3 looks very normal maybe
hinting at an e4 move at a later stage
and it just fits into the position but
he went g3 hmm yeah way it's not the bad
move was just him that somewhat
unconventional and even show is his just
playing the same thing g6 okay so i got
this can hardly believe the clock chimes
I'm not sure that the clock times for
this game are correct because we we had
a relay error and we only relatively
late God got the moves here for this
okay so 22 Queenie 7 a-4 yeah mitis
maybe try to push a 5 creating
weaknesses on the queenside so black
played 85 yeah what is the main feature
of this position yeah the main feature
of this position is that we are almost
symmetrical in a way
if you look at the Kings side yeah like
this side of the bond roller we have a
crude way to show it but this is totally
symmetrical so here everything's
basically equal both sides have
fianchetto the Queens Bishop as well and
this is also symmetrical so the only
thing that is a little bit different in
the position is is the CND file yeah we
have a situation where why does a little
bit more aggressively posted with see
493 against the 97 black will try to
let's say equal this thing as well to
play c5 and we see that we should weigh
3 c5 so the pawn structure now is
entirely symmetrical and what we get is
some kind of trade in the center and it
will revolve about around hanging pawns
anyporn structures or maybe isolated
pawn structures that happen after
captures I'm in the game we see that
after Luke c18 yeah looks are
centralized Nige b5 was played now in
this situation for example white could
have taken already here just to show one
idea if black then recaptures we could
get the typical hanging pawns those two
pawns are the hanging pawns here white
has screen b5 however attacking b7 and
85 I'm this kind of transformations are
the the story of this game on ding plays
Knight be high however does not take and
now 94 it's very logical at the night
goes away from the center to be 52 maybe
create something on the queenside and
black uses his time to jump into the
middle of the board 92 to trade of this
night and 96 so we have this straight
yeah and here ding decides to
change the overall structure this it
seems that this leads to two not much or
nothing but it's not clear that he had
anything substantially better and if
wide really wants to fight for something
here he probably has to do something
else and I've been taking on c5 this guy
keeping keeping some tension in the
position it's probably around equal
anyway but this is yeah this is a very
simplistic approach you just took the
night and took on c5 and after this we M
get to a situation where the Queen side
is completely completely frozen black
Young has two against three year and the
two points simply completely am limit
white here it's very hard to make any
progress in fact here after those trades
here a couple of trades and they flicked
in this kind of repetition and this way
I'm drew the game very quickly a bit of
a bit of a disappointing game between
the two tournament leaders I mean
eventually leading the tournament and
ding being on second place I think
probably the Chinese player was going
into this game with a mindset of playing
relatively safe yeah this some decisions
here hidden to that yeah like this III
move which is I mean run really not bad
but I mean if you are more aggressively
inclined you play stuff let let's say if
you really want to win yang with all our
might you're not going III in this
position you play very Knight c3 and
invite the the notable very sharp stuff
or you go g3 and yeah offering this this
pawn as a gambit or whatever it seems he
wanted to play a save game and and he
got a save game but there was really
nothing going on so the status quo at
them
yeah for the leading two places has not
changed here you one choke keeps us plus
three score while ding is on plus two ok
the next game are going to look at is
even shy rich against oops timber a
jabot and the most positive thing and
for up to up to now for this tournament
is that we didn't have any berlin wall
yeah this kind of opening that sometimes
leads to boring positions it's simply
like that and well he is the first
Bullen for a job off it's a bit of a
shame if he played those very sharp
lines in the in the Rue no past and no
he's one of those conduits you had to
play the Berlin defense it's really a
good opening no doubt about it but for
the spectator sometimes sometimes a bit
dry yeah char which plays d3y are not
going into the endgame them the main
line and d3 keeps a little bit more
pieces on the board however after Bishop
c5 he now decided to go for this trade
on c6 yeah this line is some has been
played really often in recent years and
also by the world champion magnus
carlsen it leads to a somewhat
simplified position with the trade where
why does this maneuvering yeah here with
those kind of moves why does maneuvering
slowly maybe hoping to get in some
favorable palm break later yeah like
maybe f4 after the right preparation um
yeah here rajab of them took a very
pragmatic decision he just took this
night yeah so white gets this pawn
structure here with the double pawn the
doubled pawns here are not weaknesses in
it the pawns their self they are not
weaknesses but they in a way um yeah
limit the flexibility of both positions
we see later that it
is about those pawns that the game is
some ya hear here we see this b5 is
coming and cherish grace Queen Queen 2g
form he could have played them in a very
simple fashion as well I could of just
for example its wide wants nothing in
this game he can always trade and play
for I had this this kind of solution and
really not much is going on here we will
probably just trade more stuff like this
and so on it's a very equal ish position
um he tried it for a little bit more
with this screen sortie and again he can
trade on b5 play a 4 and so on but he
played a for first and now we get to
this position and here um I'm not
completely sure that this is in whites
interest because while this is not far
away from being symmetrical one
difference is that white spawns a little
bit more advanced and somewhat easier to
attack we will see that in the game and
after a couple of more moves it come to
this position to this position and here
black is a little bit more active we
already see that the rookies on before
and here I think char which were being
slightly under pressure I mean really
not a lot but but a bit um he's playing
I think an inaccurate move if he goes
rook to be one now he should keep them
the Equality pretty pretty comfortably
yeah as a rookie eight for example okay
Jake oops I'm sorry rook takes before
rook takes before night b3 is one
important oh come on one important idea
to get this counter-attack against a
five yeah something like this could be
a possible line yeah and the a pawn will
guarantee that why this is okay in this
position and what he did is c3 and now
this is tricky like it's coming to the
second-ranked and yeah we see that it's
hard to get rid of this rook and he
ultimately decided to play rugby one but
now we see that with Bishop c5 later
Knight b6 on 95 we'll put very awkward
pressure on those pawns they are simply
easier to attack yeah the white knight
has no comparable activity especially
not from b1 and yeah right now is in
serious trouble after some more movie
and he had to give up the a porn and
ultimately we came to an end game black
one this pawn we came to to this to this
end game where black um definitely
should win with good technical play it's
just an extra pawn we can continue a
little bit more yeah note that here you
shouldn't take here on f2 in any case
this it's not helping and well you
cannot take here because of 94 and maybe
you can do tonight chief I even hon but
it's not necessary really yeah what Raja
loved it is perfectly perfectly fine 96
here here and now he has the C porn the
pure passer on the C file it is pretty
far away from the rest of the pawns this
is a technically winning position and he
does win it indeed with pretty little
effort what what we can take from the
technical phase of the game is that it's
a clear point for centralization yeah
Black has the bishop on b2 which looks
at the central squares and takes away a
lot of squares from the night King
coming to e6 and then died on d6 is also
nice
the place for central influence it might
come to be 5 later I think it did yeah
yeah it did come to there at that point
you know a nice little thing is that if
white steps forward here it is a really
aesthetic checkmate I believe yeah the
check is delivered by the bishop by the
pond this pawn is taking away d3 d4 is
taken away by the night III is taken
away by the bishop and the king is
taking care of those squares that's
really neat checkmate okay well why to
step back and now ultimately black
invaded him with with a king now King b5
as a nice move setting up this check
provoking white to go back and then King
see form for complete domination night
before is coming or 93 depending on
circumstance and the pawn will promote
or black will just enter to the end of
the position so a job of with a win
against even showered yeah a good game
by raja baath but shower Trillium had
had problems right out of the opening
when he allowed this somewhat
problematic porn structure with this
pawn structure he has to be very careful
not get into into serious trouble ok the
next game I'm going to look at is Wesley
so with white playing who you found
let's go to that yeah so we have ever
goes in Queens gambit declined let's in
fact a very interesting line that
nowadays is played very often on the top
level you will also see a second game
with this opening in this round between
karsland Aronian later yeah why is this
some popular nowadays one reason is that
it is a little bit it's a nice little
hybrid between the Queens gambit and the
names ooh Indian it gives black some
answers for activity it's it's more
active than let's say I'm Bishop e7 um
and it still is solid so it's a good a
good middle of the road approach let's
see what happened here Bishop g5 h6
Bishop f6 Queen f6 III this is a pretty
solid way to play this position with
Bishop g5 and age six and then tear
adium on f6 it leads to positions that i
believe to be between slightly better
for wide end and about equal we m can
continue a bit here should be 71 feature
the main feature of this position is
that we have a total symmetry in case of
pawn structure so how does the position
let's say I'm yeah what is the
difference between white and black in
this position it's peas activity why is
this better developed rukon see one
Scott the pieces actively placed here
black has so still catch up in
development what black has is the bishop
pair that's nice but hard to use anyway
because of the activity white can in any
case basically almost all the time for
some some kind of simplification to that
that black has to give up the bishop um
for example let's say this is not
particularly threatening but after a
move like an item a queen to be three
this bishop has to trade on c3 sooner or
later um yeah black has pretty good
chances to get an equal game if he or
she in this case um it's not suffering
from any direct problem right of the
opening all right right out of the
opening in the first couple of moves why
tries to activate this night and also
the Queen so it's really not a case of
where to try to use the momentum that
you have because of the better
development
96 and night b3f retreating to avoid
further trades if why does something
something very let's say um unambitious
in a way a lot like 96 the whole thing
is immediately sorry shifting towards
black Bishop is nice on c6 and it's not
clear how wide is continuing its not
like he's got a brilliant meeting attack
quickly White has to keep pieces on the
board and therefore when to be three
this is also not a retreat in a passive
sense but also something that prepares
night jumps to c5 Bishop v8 was played
and which is actually a novelty the move
f5 is known from a game Iranian are not
and in 2014 Bishop e8 is a novel team
and it seems to 2d to a decent position
I mean what does not have very much it
seems a three was played five ya know
that the time show near for black is
bogus unfortunately as mentioned there
were some problems with the transmission
of moves and times and probably due to
the fact that they played this round not
in Vikon Z but in Rotterdam there are I
think two rounds that are played in
different in different cities not invite
Guns II yeah f5 f5 counter-attacking the
night and after Queen e2m queen was
saying after Queenie to we had this have
this transformation yeah so at the
moment black as a pawn up what does
white hair for it yeah he's got this
move activating the light and attacking
those two pawns white will get something
back here and it gets very interesting
here by the way Bishop takes e6 was not
particularly good I mean no it wasn't it
wasn't terrible I mean but didn't didn't
lead to anything um I can just step 2 h8
and it's not not quite clear how white
should continue here for example if he
plays Bishop g5 that's not that's not
threatening very much I can just go like
here yeah b6 and it's pretty solid but
it's this line or did I did I'm oh I'm
sorry I'm wondering why wait is a pawn
up right sorry I read my notes wrong
after King age 8 like he had Queen B 2
in my in my own analysis yeah Bishop b5
you can claim but it's not not leading
to two very much okay he went Bishop a2
yeah it's also this is more interesting
keeping this Knight takes of e6 option
open but Black now has an interesting
way to play she went an idea three check
funny funny attacking move yeah white
cannot take because of Queen g5 King h1
and it takes f threatening mate and the
Queen so black winsome white has to play
King edge one with that much is clear
and now Queen edge for ya black is all
of a sudden getting an attack but well
it's not a very dangerous attack but it
can be dangerous and can turn out to be
dangerous if why does not really am not
really a circumspect and defense and he
now decided to to transform the position
and the next term couple of moves are
pretty much forced once why does some
deciding for that h3 was an interesting
alternative that he did not play we
analyzed 95 in the official in the
official broadcast the live broadcast
and we thought that this sum is
interesting for for both sides to play
it is ok for black gap but but nothing
special let's say also her wide nothing
special yeah h3 wasn't was a decent
alternative yeah for example when fight
takes him and goes for this black has
some King edge eight and should be five
this is the position that that white can
can try form but the problem is all the
time that black has counter-attacking
ideas yeah with sacrifices here if you
do something like that for example you
run into this kind of business
threatening queen here and look h3 made
the move h3 is something that needs to
be considered very carefully because it
it pretty much sets up for a sacrifice
on h3 so you have to be ready for that
yeah he played it simpler he took their
night and this now leads to a forced
transformation Bishop h5 now White has
to take and play Bishop g4 that was the
only way to prevent Bishop takes f three
winning in a very simple way yeah and
now takes Queen B too ok Bishop takes
rook g1 this was some the idea of the
white player he's a pawn down but he's
got some ideas on the G file all of a
son and possibly 96 is also a tactic
that comes into consideration yeah like
black takes the G file is open um so for
made on g7 very a very complicated
situation here um she went rogue f7 that
seems to be best Queen deform and age 51
covering covering the bishop on g4
93 intending to go to e5 yeah now we
have a pretty forced sequence here with
Queenie seven white now has no other
option than to trade and we enter yeah
an endgame I guess an endgame is right
but it is still a very sharp position
it's not I mean it's not really an
endgame in a technical sense but it's
all about being precise now at
calculating the upcoming complications
um the only question here really is was
there some improvement for black black
is a pawn up and potentially has a good
active bishop but we also in the
broadcast we couldn't really find a way
forward black seems to be more
comfortable but it's very hard to to
find something to improve upon her play
the way it went white got some activity
and this this pawn was taken and white
installed this this knight on f6 like
however defended them defended nicely
now with this here and in some other
situations black also had the
opportunity to take on f6 simply getting
rid of this annoying night but this is a
decision that bleeds to a very one-sided
game where only white can do something
you shouldn't lose your nerve there the
knight on f6 is a bit pesky and note
that yeah yeahs made a threat in turn
but still you shouldn't really just take
it him it's no problem to just cover
cover the mate but here White has has so
much activity that black probably cannot
think about playing for win anymore
maybe in the last couple of moose there
was an improvement but we didn't find it
in them in the live broadcast and when I
added some some of my own thoughts and
some computer checks but that also
didn't lead to anything very conclusive
um so we continue to the next very
critical position so it's taken i takes
king cakes e six this is a very very
critical position now we have a
situation with black as a partner but
this is really not the story of this
position the whole thing revolves around
the question what is happening here the
King can now possibly invade White has
the far more active king of this limb
and black ism the one needs to be
precise now and exactly here black can
easily lose I mean just to show some
some lines if you play King g7 for
example you do lose really you cannot
save the game after King e5 the idea is
root d7 and something like rook here and
f4 is strong that's a very strong move
the ideas to whatever black place you go
f5 and you're threatening f6 now so the
capture is pretty much mandatory but
look g1 check King yeah I can also go
here got this this this and this is
already forced checkmate yeah II 7mate
is the threat and this is how it starts
or answer however you want to view it
the mating sequence is starting with the
game is serve basically ending yeah it
is very dangerous really a move like
King g7 I'm just the team move I don't
know I don't know without any
calculation that say it's just losing a
move like rook c3 is also losing
probably losing I guess it's losing King
e5 let's
a king of aid f4 key 1806 the invasion
is very dangerous yeah now there are
those threats or look h12 a jade black
cannot save this she has to be really
really careful and move that seems to
draw is some given by by the engines
King f8 this really seems to draw due to
one very nice move kingi five and then
rook f3 this is a key move it has this
idea and of course the idea to capture
however this is a very very narrow path
to the draw one line that illustrates
how narrow this pad is is the following
it is a very long line but it shows us
that it's not at all an easy draw check
King g76 then the white king is very
very active look at seven rogue d7 takes
takes and we already see what will
happen here black has to sacrifice the
rook on on on d7 to ultimately get to
the draw octi to Roxy one to cover the
sea file b-47 a for Queen this this and
this is ultimately ultimately a draw I
mean this line is this is really really
long but it shows how narrow that does
this path is g5 and ultimately hear them
the king and the and the Jeep on the
draw of course not able to calculate
this so easily I mean this is not beyond
the capability of those players but it
is a very very deep line and she played
it differently and ultimately in a way
that leads to a draw but this wasn't
easy to see really not she played rook
one is a very radical solution I mean
just getting rid of one pair of rooks
and it completely it wrecks the path
structure so it it kind of does not feel
like the best solution king of eight
maybe is the clean draw but well it
seems to lead to a row ultimately me
kingi five King to g7 King to d6 yeah
note that something like this even
losing white has to be has to be a bit
careful yeah kindy six others quite
logical and there are other other tries
however white can try look a one for
example a move that we looked at during
the broadcast black I have a drawers
with rupee seven she must play that but
it isn't wrong okay form and checks this
is one key those checks from the side
route b6 check King d7 King f6 and this
is stopping the pawn this this has to be
played and rook see one setting up this
this kind of thing rook e8 yeah doesn't
look very active but there is no other
move rook e8 king e five intending to go
to f6 and here again it's a sick the
question of finding the only moves it is
probably not super difficult to do but
it's really just one misstep and you're
done she went a three the only move King
f6a to hear white also had this idea I
think this is was this is this i had
suggested I'm during the broadcast if
i'm not mistaken but black draw see as
well with rook e8
King f six and A two and why it has to
return something something like that as
a possible line this this this and here
there is no way forward for white now we
can do this kind of thing but it is
still just a draw um in the game can you
have six was played is also the more
obvious move a to it was necessary it's
still a thin line if luck goes for this
move for example to try to set up for
counter play he or she in this case will
lose a look-see five funny bouquet eight
and now the fantastic move rooks it to
the ideas f4 and rook h2 and this is in
fact winning it's kind of remarkable g5f
form takes rook h2 and King g8 root G to
check teenage 7e7 and wide wins the
paneer will promote and all those pawns
are stopped by the rook a really amazing
line there are many pitfalls but she
navigated this perfectly a to rook a1
rugby eight yeah a key move activating
the rook foi was played now yeah it's a
clear that rook a to was the main
alternative but black is drawing now um
drawing in fact with look be five or
look before but not with rook be three
because of F for some tricky lines
however look before is the most obvious
move anyway I think to have this this
check and just prevent fyy allow it um
this is this is leading to to the draw
pretty straightforwardly like this this
this this and this is a draw yep like
it's just controlling the pawn
m-f form is what he tried Luke deform
and to be played f5 takes rook takes
yeah White was giving up this pawn to
get this umbrella situation where the f
porn is the shield against the checks
from the back but black can still draw
with exactly one move rue gauge for this
was forced the only move to draw and
it's the draw because of this checks
here on age six yeah they continued for
a while black has to go back kini eight
controlling this square and again check
and back to h1 to have the check against
King f6 yeah after some more moves they
agree to a draw this was an interesting
rook endgame and they were in fact even
even more lines I skipped a couple to
make this video well this will be this
will be epically long anyway but yeah
there was even more content that's what
I'm trying to say them then what I
actually have presented okay now to the
final games of this this coverage we are
starting a not quite sure what is the
most sensible order for this and let's
do give each Obama they are all
interesting really interesting okay give
riju bomb okay classical Kings Indian so
slightly more let's say normal opening
for ljubav a standard still it's very
sharp and we get to the bionet attack in
short order and here very early in fact
your barber is coming up with a surprise
he plays Knight to f4 Bishop f1 and f5
and this line is actually known from the
very early days of them of the bionet
attack when it was some
yeah revitalized in them in the early
1990s um and back then it was the common
belief that this is a this is unplayable
like really do to Bishop takes pawn
takes d5 and the assessment back then
what that white has a fantastic
advantage and I had a look at recent
developments there is absolutely no
change to this evaluation why does
believe to be substantially better and
well the skies eighty-seven percent in
my my big database it's very surprising
that Jabara allowed that and give we
didn't play it and it's a bit mysterious
I didn't see the press conference would
be interesting to know the thing is that
this is this is really bad for black
there is there's absolutely no way to to
to get something here the problem is
that white is basically playing here
with five against four pawns and it can
be critical for black really really
quickly I mean probably he only has to
move a five now in this position if you
place any any slowish move I mean let's
say okay it looks looks weird but let's
say h6 you had to prepare g5 then see
595 it will kill you yeah this is a
winning position already white has
possibilities like that i had this on
the pod once in a tournament game and
this was like I mean I won this game
spent I think 20 minutes on the clock
and it was some it was resigns after
about 20 moves um i really don't know
why he didn't check on f4 he went a form
this is not leading to a bad position
but it's very mysterious why they right
zubaba allowed that and key we didn't
play it okay we get to a very very sharp
position now look a three an interesting
move setting up possibilities to get the
rook over not as an attacking device but
this is a prophylactic move it might
cover
the third-ranked and we see that this
will become important later in the game
it also keeps the g3 night protected
which looks unimportant but well it is
important let's see g for a 5 h 5 so
both sides are playing on their own as
Joe Benjamin stated yeah they push their
their pawns forward they care about
their business and they ignore the other
side ok 94-96 takes takes Knight b5 yeah
that looks very very logical and white
is attacking this this weakness on d6
how is black going to defend this yeah
he has to play Luke f6 they reach this
position and this is some I mean we had
critical situations earlier but this is
the first really really critical
position um that is not within the
knowledge of theory that same the big
question here for Geary was should
should you play g3 or not the move g3 he
played it I can tell you that much the
move g3 looks some it is always a
problem if you move pawns in front of
your king when you are the side that is
under attack here like has already a
couple of pieces near the king and very
often you don't want to move the pawns
however here g3 is of course a very very
um yeah direct way to refute what black
black is setting up here let's say the
night the night cannot move let's start
with that if the night moves somewhere I
mean let's say they gives a check while
it's going to take and can even play
Bishop g5 and this is really not working
at all yeah so pin d6 faults and yeah
black has no attack you cannot move the
night at all I mean retreating is also
also quite terrible note that we already
see that this rook
is doing something in terms of these
protecting a little bit on them on the
King side so g3 essentially it's like
it's called like calling a bluff in a
way and let's say show me show me what
you got um and what Jabara really showed
him something we would see I will see
what happens my suggestion when we
broadcast this live was Bishop e3 I
didn't want to move move pawns there and
it seems to be not that bad like this
for example then takes complicated stuff
I mean I would still be very afraid yes
wide like has many pieces near the near
the king um this also just look quite
okay for y now but g3 well from a
technical point of view if you give it
to a chess engine it says g3 wins but
that's only half of the story we see if
we see what happens take stakes and a
six yeah in this position on white
hadn't had a possibility to to win even
more material here we could have played
Knight b6 going for this rook in the
corner takes takes and probably f take
see form what a positioner why it has
one in exchange and them f4 night is
hanging a very very tense situation and
very hard to evaluate ultimately Geary
didn't go for that it is really very
unclear something like let's say takes
him can be answered with Bishop to F 596
as a possible line and then black takes
and what position is that black is a
lockdown complete look but those pawns
are very very dangerous if you imagine a
situation where black has pushed f3 the
White King can be checkmated really
really quickly
yeah Queen some o2h for Luke to h6
something having this is very dangerous
um give you went 93 and after this we
get the most spectacular move of this
tournament so far funny enough by the
tail end of the of the field ljubav are
now played the amazing move Knight to H
fire setting up a self fork in a way
there so he already had one night
hanging and he puts the second night
also up for the taking and yeah now the
situation is completely unclear yeah I
mean unclear in a way like dynamic
equality and if you analyze it a little
bit deeper a shocking move really um the
first thing to check is well can you
take it well you can't after this rook
age six and then queen age for white
will lose yeah it's there's no defense
to this attack for example if we look at
this checkmate is a threat and here
black has all the time in the world
Bishop takes yeah those pieces are not
helping that much and f3 is going to hit
yeah let's say here here
and we'll give aid this is a decisive
attack White has absolutely no defense
to this black it's not even material
down here it's just just a partner the
tech is this is far too strong can you
take the other night nope for me to come
note that if white tries to tries to
sacrifice the Queen to somehow continue
we're not even taking that this will
lead to a mate in very short of honor
yeah so you cannot take the Knights so
what did he do giving it took to quite a
known thing and then played knight to e
to ya this is a very good practical
solution to this it tries to trade the g
for night it not only tries it
accomplishes to trade the night and it
shows right this rook can be a useful
piece in this case it was used to
sacrifice the exchange and what he
managed where this is to get rid of both
attacking Knights black now took only
two that's better than I'm taking here
this position is really nice for white
as a that's secure that's not right this
is a secure configuration pressure on d6
now and white will pick up this poets
that's really nice for white so this is
better we see that here here black has
one of the exchange for one pawn so why
it has an ID and a pawn for the rook
which is almost sufficient compensation
anyway in terms of material but wyd also
has some other assets here like nights
can be to be six so it is a position
with with compensation I'm Bishop to h6
trading this Bishop makes lots of sense
kingi to we had to get rook age one in
black now traded and f4 it's possible
that this was a bit more precise white
really didn't have any special attack
going and one point of this move is that
if white now wants to go to the age
where we can actually take and look at
this f2 f2 point f4 is allowing rook h1
which is not really a problem but maybe
Queen f8 was a little bit more precise
route g6 look h5 Queen f8 Queen h1 note
that one feature of this this position
is that the night on b6 is just limiting
those two pieces very considerably the
night cannot move I sorry the bishop
cannot move the only possible square
would be G forward other than that he's
bit paralyzed on the other hand it's not
clear how wide them is going to increase
his pressure Queen you have six Queen h2
Queen h2 is a clever move it just passes
the right to move to black and ask them
in a way ok what are you going to do
it's an in fact not so easy to do
anything is black or to do something
takes takes Queen g7 this is what the
computer suggests suggests um after that
it probably is equal there are some ways
to illustrate that maybe like this in
this line for example we get to a
situation where where does equal yeah if
white tries to avoid the perpetual by
taking after Luke f80 risks to be he
risks to be worse in the game ljubav are
played a different move he didn't take
on g3 he played after some thought the
move Bishop to g4 and it turns out that
this is losing its just losing on the
spot
takes takes and now the move Queen age
three yeah we mostly during the live
broadcast looked at 97 but this is this
is a bit complicated Queen g6 as the
point after which Knight takes Queen
takes and this is in fact leading to a
draw by a perpetual check I mean it's
not totally obvious maybe but it is
really the case white cannot really am
do something against it on the move
Queen age three I mean 97 by the way is
winning but you have to be very precise
the more queen Ashley is much much
simpler and what is blacks move now he
actually played this move but what else
is there you cannot do this because of
Luke age eight if you go here you're
running into this and you have yeah you
have just killed the counter play with
Queen to Queen g6 m wide winds also very
effortlessly has effort Leslie Queen g6
was played the point is that now after
the rook check here here black is
getting this move in and draws funny
move this is in fact a perpetual check
quite remarkable it's however not
necessary why it has a much better move
and this was played by Gary the final
move of the game king of three funnier
the King steps forward it covers efore
and the threatens Queen takes default
and the rook is basically trapped now
yeah the only way to try to save it is
this but then you go here take pH and
black does not even have a check so why
does white is completely winning yeah
after king of 3g baba resigned the game
yeah what a shame it was a it was a
really great attacking effort
I mean this was really great here what a
shocker yeah it's really deserve them at
least have a point I'd say that it does
not help him if you make them relatively
when simple is the wrong word but it's a
when you look at this I mean if you
calculate Bishop g4 takes takes what
kind of move on I you are you are you
what are you calculating here I mean
queen adria certainly move you should
check in 97 in fact also wins it's just
more complicated so this is really not
working at all the move Bishop g4 maybe
he just wanted wanted too much and
didn't really consider this to be yeah
good enough maybe you just wanted I mean
not taking us actually more precise
takes takes and all this maybe he simply
wanted more and and discarded this on
that account it's hard to tell but a
very spectacular and interesting game
yeah with this result geary ism moving
up to a plus one score and joe bhava
really would just a draw out of five
rounds you're havin a miserable
tournament or started with this this
over side yeah in round one way he
blundered into the losing king of born
in game against you on sugar yeah let's
continue we still have two games to go
and we're already one hour into this
video yeah I suspected it would be quite
long but well yeah let's let's continue
we have whiter check harness love water
check with right against carwin are the
world number two with black yeah what a
shake is a default player here we go and
what is kiwana playing now very
interestingly he's going for f5 playing
the dutch defense just as Carlton did
against water shake our dinner went for
a different move order but it's still
funny that caruana is doing
same opening okay see 49 f 6 g 3 we get
a somewhat different setup now in fact
we get the modern main line of the
leningrad touch with c6 the mostly six
in recent years gained prominence over
Queenie eight Queenie eight was the
traditional main line here since the
late 1980s when it was champion via
Vladimir male nuke amongst others and we
can't gurevich those were the pioneers
of the landing good Dutch back then
nowadays it is believed that white maybe
has a little something with d5 p.m. one
after c6 which is the move that is
played also in this game while after c6
the move d 5 has lost some of its appeal
due to e5 it was already known beckham
for a long time that 'if I've is a solid
for black but some games have shown that
this kind of structure is really not to
be feared the d6 pawn looks weak but
black has a very good central control
what this f5 bonus is very essential in
controlling you form and it seems that
why it has nothing there there were a
game a couple of games by karuna camera
by the way who showed blanks chances
very convincingly in this disposition
type so white started to play other
murcia kramnik played queen rook be one
for example yeah well here rook e1 is
played night a6 typical way to develop
the night in the in the lending go dutch
yeah very often a night development like
this is not really that great because of
the e6 square being weak yeah you're
very often one to the night here this
can be in actually a pretty decent post
yeah i'm looking here okay be 394 takes
this happened 95 funny idea yeah the
night is using this little tactic on
let's say tactic is a bit much this pin
to reposition itself 95 to prevent
direct 94 d 5 so we mixing a lennon
gridded stone hoy now 92 h3 here here
yeah why Knight to h3 he wants to get
here ultimately the night on d3 is very
nicely placed yeah what is this position
how to evaluate it and probably why it
is a little bit better but it shouldn't
be anything very substantial let's see
how it continues this a 5 a-4 yeah and
now kawana initiates and initiates a
very active active plan that looked
quite normal to us also in the broadcast
but at the end of the day it's not clear
that this is so great he played the
moose b5 very active and somewhat in
spirit of the Dutch and the landing-grid
in particular you have to have to be
active because some of the strategic
features of the position are not really
in your favor but b5 let's say let's see
what happened takes cakes here this this
position was was coming up and the
question is what about this a pawn is
this a weakness as Y to shake played it
it looked really really like this is a
big weakness he went rogue a 3 this is
strong move with Queen a one being a
possibility and a very funny thing is if
you think back the game why to shake
cards and what is checking on the a pawn
in this
game against the world champion as well
and here look what happens hmm this bond
is falling like it's starting a
counter-attack on the Kings side and
that's it for the pawn yeah where did it
go wrong it's not so easy to say maybe
the b5 plan is really yeah maybe it's
really not not the way to go it's hard
to find an improvement over the course
of this moves you probably can be can be
more precise but the idea f3 sorry f
three bishops III we have to do it
differently to get them get the arrows
f3 bishops III king or queen a1 this
regrouping piling up on the pawn is very
difficult to counter I mean hmm have you
don't know how an idea that I had in the
during the broadcast was I actually had
I propose this move trying to put it on
b5 but this is probably also not leading
to that much if we think about this say
here yeah and again now even Queen d2
okay one yet I don't know probably the
airport is just a weakness yeah b5 maybe
this is to lose now the way it went in
the game the a pawn got lost and Kiwanis
started this started this King side
attack this is a good move rook see one
now this prepares Bishop II one as a
defense and also 95 this is how it
developed got this trades and and now we
only have bishops on the board no nights
means that the position is becoming a
little bit more little bit more
static yeah the nights always yeah give
some some what's the word like
quirkiness it makes the position often a
bit less predictable and here and we see
that why does enjoying this pawn and
where's Blake's play um kawana played
this nicely actually played 'if i move
that not so easily comes to you as you i
think that d 4head FYI just prevents
that but it is a playable move the point
is that after something like f takes
like will take take and play Bishop e7
white has very decent compensation for
the exchange that he will lose but at
least the position and it gets out of
balance balances also this is not a
balanced position but it adds some some
some some chaos to the to the situation
that Kara wanna has welcomed as
welcoming whitish echo ever did not even
go for that he took and went to be one
attacking f5 not a not a bad option
black takes he took on f5 yeah and now
um it becomes some very interesting
Queenie 6mm was an option here probably
a better option to limit the the
disadvantage that that black has um he
played Queen III however very obvious
move on but it seems not a very good one
after Bishop f2 he retreated and now
white could have gotten a really clear
advantage with the move not this with
the move Queen to be one the idea is to
set up this configuration where a
possible Bishop f5 will be a very big
issue for the g4 porn White has a very
substantial advantage
he played this however and after this it
wasn't that bad anymore for black here
he could have played rook a3 and after
this is not clear that that why does
having having that much for example
after before the move d3 is leading to
very dangerous counterplay know that
it's equal material why does not up any
material yes the B Parliament like while
this is a double pawn this is also an
advanced versa so this is giving enough
counter play instead of rook a three but
whether we have to note that Kara wanna
had no time on the clock very very
limited time he played d3 trying to
activate activate the bishop on on f6
and it really seems that this is not
leading to to anything why took it and
deform knowbe4 was played black can try
to stir up some trouble now but
ultimately the beep on will decide the
game he tried Bishop to b3 b5
yo the pawn bishop e7 note that if he
tries bishop here we should be four is
covering this thing but should wear
three is a very serious threat but we
can cover it d3 thats a rock d 5 for
this is a plausible line that ultimately
leads to a winning position for white
rock g6 our md5 this is what he played
with after Luke h5 rookie one we should
be too he won the g pawn rook be to
Brooke f3 Bishop before and b6 the pawn
is ultimately just promoting yeah and
carwin i assume is yeah he resigned now
and lost this game in the Dutch defense
just as magnus carlsen did three days
ago against Roddick water shake so what
to check one two games with white on the
on the white side of the lending a Dutch
against the world number one and the
world number to a fantastic result and
he now were these two wins is also in
them in the group to to pursue even
Chuck who's dealing with plus three
which is now on plus to excellent result
by Reuters check yeah maybe koalas
opening choice and ultimately yeah costs
him it seems that way to shake is
playing this kind of position
excellently on the white side winning
against the two best players in the
world in the in the time span of three
days this is quite remarkable okay one
more game in this coverage cards and
Aronian yeah I've say saved this for
last by no but for no particular reason
to be honest it was so just the way of
the printout went for my notes okay
let's see we have a real goes in again
Bishop g5 age six and council is keeping
it simple just as his this is basically
his his trademark style he just takes on
f6 here Bishop h4 is possible but leads
to very very sharp complications after
g5 for example or sometimes even see
five and then g5 yeah um you just took
takes takes is Queen fo sorry this this
this line is not considered to be very
very critical against the there goes in
but what it does it it leads to very um
yeah let's say tidy positions you have
positions that are mostly about
strategic planning and this is of course
what colin is excellent about this is
all very normal Bishop d6y a blackhead
played a six to make sure that 95 is not
hitting and wide retreats with the Queen
that's the typical way to play it you
have played Queen to a four to force the
knight to c6 where is not optimally
placed but you had to spend some time
with the Queen in the process now White
has this night a 42 c5 idea in this
position black very often seeks counter
plane on them on the Kings side and i'm
not sure if aronian setup 97 looks
normal but now the the setup that he
that he goes for and the next couple of
moves looks a bit dubious to me and also
to the to the other commentators I mean
Joe Benjamin wasn't so skeptical about
blacks chances but we see that black is
getting into into some issues relatively
quickly before and and here the next
move I really don't don't like that one
he played the plate now Knight to c8
when when I saw this I was thinking that
he probably angles for this idea trying
to put the night ii m maybe even be five
96-94 but the strange thing is that well
cousin played night a form going for
this this Destin square and now black
went b6 preventing that when you intend
to do that why had to put night on sait
in the first place I really don't don't
know the rationale behind that maybe he
wanted to provoke exactly that so I mean
maybe he was thinking I'm threatening
night be sick so he actually has to do
this but why does not subjecting to that
I believe so the thing that that makes
me skeptical about this is the whole
idea i mean if you look at this why does
regrouping to d3 which is not a bad
square the night is looking at many
critical spots here 96 a form i was
there i was aiming at this position here
in this situation White has various
ideas one ideas even also to go a 5 and
black felt inclined to prevent that with
this and now we get this position and
this was basically what Aronian allow it
with this night see 8b 6 set up this
structure the pure structure is just
very nice for white the c7 porn and the
d5 pawn they need some protection and if
you just imagine any type of endgame
that might arise a minor piece endgame
almost all of them rook endgames all of
those are just a lot better for wide and
this makes the play difficult for black
to conduct because you cannot allow
trades so easily if we see what happened
in the game m wide doubled 92 g 3 strong
move
strengthening the the Kings side and
this this is a trademark of release this
is a really strong move yeah it does not
look very apparent yeah why it has
structurally speaking a nice bishop why
does he trade it the point is any trade
favors right in this position as
mentioned all the end games a good
friend and looked at look at this
position with the bishops traded the d5
pawn has actually become a little bit
more vulnerable the bishop only six
while not being very great it at least
covered the pawn but this has gone now
and see that a move like Wiener three
sets black very very annoying problems
he really cannot take getting to this
end game would be a torture yeah Knight
to e5 as an idea and those weaknesses
they don't go away note that it move
like f6 which covers if five runs into
this kind of situation and here you're
almost lost it really it just is it's
that bad so we had to keep the Queen's
on the board Queen g5 h form and luke c6
and it's just very uncomfortable for
black this kind of situation you have no
activity whatsoever and why it has all
the time in the world to try to improve
the trades as mentioned are all
unfavorable for you very difficult
position to play Knight f6 normal I
guess night a form and here black had to
hang on with something like Bishop to
before probably yeah this this kind of
move we should be formed not not quite
sure what wireless do i can even retreat
the Queen black whatever he should do we
shouldn't move anything agent do
anything substantial he just has to sit
and wait which is never a really good
good thing a good situation to be
but the thing is what he did he did
something but this some really backfired
badly g6 was Aronian smooth but this
really yeah it almost loses I guess
after age five sorry um black really has
no move after that the normal looking
movers g5 but white can really just take
yeah and this is really winning it's not
even like better for what it's a winning
position and the big problem is that
there is also this year how do you
untangle very difficult let's say black
is playing I don't really see a move if
you move the bishop yeah then then this
hits if you move this this is coming
this really no defense yeah in the game
he went King g7 but this is not helping
either takes takes Knight takes it takes
and here no alternatively Bishop a3 is
answered by this and wins yeah he took
on g3 Queen back and 9c form very
comparable to the line that we had had
seen before yeah here the point is that
g6 is under much pressure there is 95 as
a big threat and sometimes night x 26
there is no no defense to that look f8
was played 95 now with a fork
essentially took it and now g6 is
falling always checks and now the final
touches the move whoopsie form
it's the quickest way to win there were
other wins but this is using the final
piece in the tag he went with this check
yeah line two to calculate for wide was
check and check and but you have a form
this was the little key move that had to
be seen before hand after Queen takes
Rugare 6 why does some going to win in
short order the aronan gave this check
and went for a rookie Jade but why does
just having this the size of attack with
with his heavy pieces and he Aronian
resigned there is no defense anymore you
can do something like this but this is
winning now cutting the connection
between the two pieces after Queen takes
the check is the decisive move winning
the Queen so a win for cars the second
win in a row he started very very slow
way losing against whiter shake after
some drawers and but now two wins
against when vini and mal against
Aronian yeah cousin has an excellent
score now against aronia and he hasn't
lost to him since 2009 really a long
time and aronia is really looking out of
shape in this event I mean he had a
pretty rotten 2014 anyway after winning
tata steel in the in the first weeks of
the year and never he never really got
to to a good form and this continuous
Enda and the tata steel diamond this
year he's on minus 2 i'm not mistaken
and this is a really in no way um
reflecting his actual actual strength
when he is in good shape yeah cardenas
in contention again with the +1 and well
he will play today um when this video is
released he will play em against him
kawada so very important and counter
kawana with the white pieces let's see
will be interesting I hope yeah I hope
you enjoyed this very long video but
this was around full of interesting
games so it was difficult to make it
really really brief yeah thanks for
watching